your mindset must have shifted being in
prison and being a comedian i want to
know like short-term goals what they
were that ended you in prison versus
what your long-term
you know
financial
uh meaningful gratification
um
is these days after being you know in
jail versus being out of jail short-term
versus long-term how are you processing
this
so
you you ask the question my short-term
goal that got me in yeah well how your
how short-term versus long-term has
changed um
i i don't think that
i didn't have a goal when i was in the
street hustling it was a in that's an
endless goal like
i didn't it wasn't a set amount of money
i wanted to make or i didn't have a oh
i'm gonna do this for this my time i'm
gonna do it until i'm tired of doing it
or until i get busted or until somebody
kill me it that's the
that was the there was no game plan it
was just wake up and hustle i don't
think i don't think any
uh and and let me frame this
because i i when i talk i gotta i've
i've learned to put it in the proper era
because it's different eras of the game
so
in my era i started selling dope in
1987.
so
in 87
i don't have a
end game for this
you know now if i would have
went past 19
if i would have been in my 20s selling
dope i probably would have had
oh i want to make this and then get out
this but this is
i'm i'm 19. you know i'm
14 15 16 17.
man i'm just making the money
but and it wasn't continuous like i sold
then i stopped
and then
at 16
is really when it went crazy for me like
i'm
i'm a
real street dough boy with a lot of
bread and i'm 16 years old
[Music]
so when you 17 and you got about
400 000 and you're 17 years old
and don't nobody even know that you have
this money and you riding around in
a
79 monte carlo
with 30 40 000 in the trunk at all times
i don't have any end goals
like my boys went to school one goal he
reaches when you start in that game i
feel like if you're good you reach the
angle pretty quick like you start to
make decent money right
nah it
and that's a good question too it's a
patient thing too exactly that's the
question yeah you start off hustling
like i i i heard when i
when i listen to people talk about
anything that i've been a part of
whether
going to prison
whether
doing a special i don't care what if i
know the process of it i just listen and
be like this oh wow that was pretty
that's pretty quick
you know to do it but the era
so
new jack city came out 1991. what's his
name this thing i've been selling dope
in 1987.
wow so i wasn't influenced by new jack
city
and
nino brown
they didn't have in the movie
they didn't have a goal they just
selling just like
with
frank lucas and
um frank matthews and frank matthews was
like
he's the only drug dealer that never got
caught
and he was a part of the french
connection
so
now frank lucas frank matthews two
different people
he didn't have an end goal
like there's no end goal in the drug
game and when i hear people say well i
was gonna do this to get this i was like
what age were you
that you had this wherewithal to right
i'm still
i'm still trying to figure out how to
get away from the cops
ultimately there was there was no end in
sight there was no game plan there was
no goal it was just wake up
the police had the end game like one of
these days we're going to catch him and
stop him
[Music]